el si comenzamos nosotros esta cobertura
miren esta belleza
el jaguar field de org
y para mí siempre es un placer estar
aquí y venir en representación de mi
país venezuela
y lista para defender sus colores listas
para para dar lo mejor de mí y lista
para para intentar
entregarlo todo como lo hago siempre en
la pista julie todo listo preparados
todo listo todo preparado todo ya
afinado para para mi participación aquí
en este campeonato lo mayor lo más
importante el primer salto después del
primer asalto lo que venga siempre ha
sido así el primero el primer salto lo
más importante después vino el salto a
darlo todo
jóvenes